says among all the memorabilia he has
these birds remind him the most of his
late son Mustafa
he says he takes care of them every day
in the same way his son used too
Mustafa was a senior year university
student of administration and economics
in Baghdad he was killed by a sniper
during the 2019 Nationwide protesters
against the government
my son was like all other ambitious
protesters with a revolutionary urged
due to frustration they saw sons of
corrupt politicians having lots of money
while they didn't have a penny they were
disappointed by a political status and
corrupt regime created by both Iran and
the United States so they developed a
state of awareness and desire to make a
change
three years ago Iraq was shaken by the
largest demonstrations in its modern
history
proud smashed in baghdad's tahrir square
as people demanded jobs better services
and an interstate corruption
the numbers grew and the demonstrations
spread south leading to the resignation
of former prime minister Adil Abdul
Mahdi nearly 700 protesters were killed
by Security Forces tens of thousands
were injured
and many cases of abductions and force
disappearances were reported
while both the current and previous
governments have pledged to ensure
accountability for violations and abuses
linked to the demonstration's
victims families and human rights
organizations are still concerned
human rights activists accuse
iran-backed groups of carrying out the
killings
concerned authorities have deliberately
concealed the identity of perpetrators
which it names as a third party because
some official institutions are involved
in the Crackdown against dissident
voices and others have manipulated the
protests to suit their interests
keeps records of people killed along
with his son including those in other
provinces
he says messages have been left on the
door's step of his house warning him to
stop
this is what remains of Mustafa in his
family's house his father says his sons
of friends took some of his clothes to
Keep A Memory of him
to keep alive his quest and to continue
seeking Justice for his death
foreign